hello
um
thank you
hey how you doing
the abuse are bigger sure
how you doing
attention the Press treatment will begin
in two minutes the screen will get into
in two minutes thank you
thank you
how you feeling
better
right yeah
our chairs
because I wonder
all right good afternoon everybody
you're good okay no losing pens
all right today the covid-19 public
health emergency ends and I want to take
just a moment to talk about the
important work that has happened under
this Administration to prepare the
nation for the next phase of our
response to covet 19. today the
Administration has taken significant
steps to ensure Americans have continued
access to life-saving protections such
as vaccines treatments and tests
following the expiration of the public
health emergency under this President we
launched the largest adult vaccination
program in U.S history with over 270
million Americans receiving at least one
shot of covid-19 vaccine and as you all
know our efforts have not been limited
to the United States alone our
government has been the largest single
donor of vaccines
having shared nearly 700 million doses
with 117 countries around the world
since January 20th 2021 covid-19 deaths
have declined by 95 percent new covid-19
hospitalizations are down nearly 90
percent and covid-19 deaths globally are
at their lowest levels
but I want to be clear this
Administration takes the threat of
future surges or pandemics very
seriously which is why access to vaccine
tests and treatments will remain widely
available after today where we're
protecting millions of people who are
uninsured by providing them with the
tools they need to stay protected from
Cova 19
projects like next-gen run out of run
out of HHS will invest at least five
billion dollars to accelerate the rapid
development of Next Generation vaccine
and treatments we're working to tackle
the effects of long covet and ensure
people who are experiencing it have the
help that they need we're working to
stand up the office of pandemic
preparedness and response here at the
White House and we're calling on
Congress through the president's budget
to invest in our nation's ability to
prepare and respond to Future threats so
the work won't stop but it won't stop
today but the nation is well prepared to
manage the risk of covid-19 going
forward
and the continued availability of
vaccinations tests and treatments and
programs that provide Equitable access
to these tools has put the nation and
the world in a strong position as the
public health emergency for covid-19
ends and we move into the next phase of
our response this morning you all saw we
continued progress on our efforts to
bring inflation down the official
measure of inflation for producers of
goods and services fell to 2.3 percent
that's the average rate of producer
price inflation in 2018 and 2019 and the
lowest level in more than two years and
it follows news we received yesterday
showing that consumer inflation declined
for 10 months in a row that includes a
second month of falling grocery prices
so while there is more work to do to
level to lower costs for families we are
making important progress at a time when
our job market remains historically
strong unemployment is at its lowest
level in more than 50 years the share of
working age Americans in the workforce
is the highest in 15 years in
unemployment for African Americans at is
at the lowest that we've ever seen our
historic recovery and falling inflation
is thanks to in part because of the
president's work and what he's done over
the last two years including lowering
costs for prescription drugs insulin
energy bills and gas with that thank you
for your time I'd like to introduce as
we have promised Secretary of Homeland
Security Alejandro mayorcas to provide
you all with uh with the update on the
aura bus work underway as title 42 lifts
later today
the guitar the podium is yours thank you
very much Karen and good afternoon
tonight at 11 59 PM eastern time the
pandemic era title 42 Public Health
order will end starting at midnight
people who arrive at our Southern border
will be subject to our immigration
enforcement authorities under title 8 of
the United States code
here is what that means if anyone
arrives at our Southern border after
midnight tonight they will be presumed
ineligible for Asylum and subject to
steeper consequences for unlawful entry
including a minimum five-year ban on
re-entry and potential criminal
prosecution
the transition to title 8 processing
will be Swift and immediate we have
surged 24 000 border patrol agents and
officers thousands of troops contractors
and over a thousand Asylum officers and
judges to see this through
we are clear-eyed about the challenges
we are likely to face in the days and
weeks ahead and we are ready to meet
them
we expected to see large numbers of
encounters initially we are already
seeing High numbers of Encounters in
certain sectors
this places an incredible strain on our
Personnel our facilities and our
communities with whom we partner closely
we prepared for this moment for almost
two years and our plan will deliver
results
it will take time for those results to
be fully realized and it is essential
that we all take this into account
our current situation is the outcome of
Congress leaving a broken outdated
immigration system in place for over two
decades despite unanimous agreement that
we desperately need legislative reform
it is also the result of congress's
decision not to provide us with the
resources we need and that we requested
our efforts within the constraints of
our broken immigration system are
focused on ensuring that the process is
safe orderly and Humane all while
protecting our dedicated Workforce and
our communities
I want to be very clear
our borders are not open
people who cross our border unlawfully
and without a legal basis to remain will
be promptly processed and removed
an individual who is removed under title
eight is subject to at least a five-year
ban on re-entry into the United States
and can face criminal prosecution if
they attempt to cross again
Smugglers have been long hard at work
spreading false information that the
Border will be open they are lying
to people who are thinking
of making the journey to our Southern
border know this Smuggler's care only
about profits not people do not risk
your life and your life savings only to
be removed from the United States if and
when you arrive here
our approach to build lawful safe and
orderly Pathways for people to come to
the United States and to impose tougher
consequences on those who choose not to
use those Pathways works
President Biden has led the largest
expansion of lawful Pathways in decades
people from Cuba Haiti Venezuela
Venezuela and Nicaragua have arrived
through lawfully available Pathways and
we reduce border encounters from these
groups by 90 percent between December of
last year and March of this year
we are launching new and expanded family
reunification parole processes for
Nationals of Colombia Cuba El Salvador
Guatemala Haiti and Honduras and are
increasing use of the CBP one mobile app
for individuals to schedule appointments
at our ports of Entry
to those who do not use our available
lawful Pathways we will deliver tougher
consequences using our immigration law
authorities
the new rule finalized yesterday
presumes that those who do not use
lawful Pathways to enter the United
States are ineligible for Asylum it
allows us the United States to remove
individuals who do not establish a
reasonable fear of persecution
we announced that eligible families will
be placed in expedited removal
proceedings and those that receive a
final negative credible fear
determination will generally be removed
within 30 days of being placed in those
proceedings
we began planning in 2021 for the end of
title 42. just a few highlights
in addition to securing the first
increase in Border Patrol agent hiring
in more than a decade we are in the
process of surging Personnel to the
Border including over 1 400 DHS
Personnel one thousand processing
coordinators and an additional 1 500
Department of Defense personnel
we are delivering tougher consequences
for unlawful entry during the first half
of this fiscal year we returned removed
and expelled more than 665 000 people
we are conducting dozens of removal
flights each week and we continue to
increase them just yesterday we work
with the Mexican Government to expel
nearly 1 000 Venezuelans who did not
take advantage of our available lawful
Pathways to enter the United States
we are bolstering the capacity of local
governments and ngos last week we
announced the distribution of an
additional 332 million dollars to
support communities along the south
southern border and in the interior of
our country
and we are going after the Smugglers
leading an unprecedented law enforcement
disruption campaign that has led to the
arrest of more than ten thousand
Smugglers who mislead and profit from
vulnerable migrants
the United States is also working
closely with regional Partners to impose
stiffer consequences at our border
expand lawful Pathways for orderly
migration and coordinate enforcement
efforts
this includes Mexico announcing for the
first time ever that they will accept
the returns under title eight
authorities of Nationals of Cuba Haiti
Nicaragua and Venezuela so that we can
continue the parole processes that have
been so successful in reducing migration
from those countries
it includes working with Colombia and
Panama to launch a historic
anti-smuggling campaign in the darien to
Target criminal networks that prey on
migrants
and it includes dramatically scaling up
the number of removal flights we can
operate to countries throughout the
hemisphere including Colombia Peru and
Ecuador
we are
we are a nation of immigrants and a
nation of laws we are doing everything
possible to enforce those laws in a safe
orderly and humane way
we are working with countries throughout
the region addressing a regional
challenge with regional Solutions
we again
yet again
call on Congress to pass desperately
needed immigration reform and deliver
the resources clear authorities and
modernized processes that we need
good afternoon
um I have two questions one is
um how do you decide which nationalities
are going to be able to use the legal
Pathways for example with the
Venezuelans and the um
how did you decide who is allowed to
build themselves a legal papers and who
isn't on that particular track
um for the parole programs that yes so
what we did is we met the need with the
parole programs that was the demographic
that was causing us the greatest
challenge at our Southern border and we
tailored our parole processes
accordingly
so we have shifted our programs
according to the needs that we need to
meet so you'll recall uh perhaps that in
November we developed the parole process
for Venezuelans that was then the most
significant challenge we pivoted in
January to not only expand the program
for Venezuelans but also expand it for
Cubans Haitians and nicaraguans so we
will meet the moment and on overcrowding
um if the border patrol facilities are
overcrowded and some migrants have to be
released does that send the very message
you're trying to avoid which is that
people will be released into the
interior so uh I have to say two things
in response number one
we cannot overstate the extraordinary
talent and heroism of the United States
border patrol and the Personnel of the
Department of Homeland Security that are
managing through an extraordinary
Challenge and doing so successfully
number one number two it is very
important to understand that the great
majority of people
uh will be removed if they do not
qualify for Relief under the laws of the
United States
thank you very much secretary mariorkis
you talked about all the Personnel that
you're surging to the Border you didn't
mention FEMA personnel and the Mayors
and County judges in order Townsend
we've spoken to say that what they
really need is not just FEMA dollars but
FEMA Personnel themselves to house and
feed these migrants as your department
releases them why not send FEMA
Personnel to the border the way you
would in any other emergency well the um
the deployment of FEMA Personnel is
specific to a particular type of
emergency an emergent event this is an
ongoing challenge that quite frankly has
vexed this country for decades because
this country has been unable Congress
has been unable to pass immigration
reform that everyone agrees and
understands is desperately needed we are
working with an immigration system that
was last performed in the 1990s
migration has changed dramatically since
then and we need our laws updated
hands are tied and you can't send FEMA
Personnel even if you wanted to no I'm
not saying that at all and as a matter
of fact our female Personnel are
coordinating with local communities and
cities across the country to provide
them with the information they need and
FEMA is going to be playing a pivotal
role in our shelter and services program
that is poised to distribute
363 million dollars to cities and
communities in need of funding
I'm wondering about your Communications
with foreign countries have you had
conversations in the last couple days or
so with any foreign government officials
ahead of this lifting so um I I should
take a step back and say when I speak of
the fact that it is a regional challenge
for which Regional Solutions are needed
let me let me put a finer point on that
there are approximately 20 million
displaced people throughout our
hemisphere the challenge that we are
encountering at our Southern border is
by no means unique to the southern
border of the United States and I have
learned that powerfully not only through
the information and Analysis that we
undertake in the United States
government but in our conversations with
our foreign Partners just this week I
spoke with a foreign Secretary of Panama
last week I spoke with the president of
Guatemala three weeks ago I was in
Panama to speak with the Panamanian
foreign minister and the Colombian
foreign minister we are engaged and of
course secretary blinken is leading the
Diplomatic engagements
diplomacy is a key pillar of our effort
[Music]
for the invasions not a Joffrey who has
met with President Biden on this issue
and other civil rights leaders said that
the lifting of title 42 suppresses black
Asylum Seekers who are required to ask
for asylum in countries they Transit
through many of those countries are too
dangerous for black migrants to request
Asylum and she gives the example of the
African-Americans who travel to Mexico
some were killed they were thought to be
Haitian migrants what do you say to that
what is an is there an effort and what
will you do to safety net or Safeguard
some of these black migrants who are
trying to come down for Asylum who are
in countries or transiting through
countries where they cannot ask for
Asylum through under the laws that the
five demonstrations put so so let me let
me share with you one way in which
migration has changed dramatically
um over the years it is no longer the
case that individuals can on their own
reached the southern border of the
United States they have to place their
lives and their life savings in the
hands of Ruthless Smugglers that exploit
them and ruthlessly do so and we have
not only a security obligation but a
humanitarian obligation to cut those
Smugglers out and that is indeed what we
are doing and this president President
Biden has rebuilt our Refugee processing
capabilities and has committed to a
large number of refugee admissions to
the United States our president
President Biden has expanded lawful
Pathways for migrants like no other
president passed and what we are doing
is we are extending an out outstretched
arm of humanitarian relief to reach
people where they are so they do not
have to place their lives in the hands
of those smuggling organs
the southern border is not just Mexicans
it is Haitians it's Africans if we as
we've seen particularly with that issue
with the Haitians being whipped with the
rains or the horses
but what is there well let me just uh
correct you right there because actually
the investigation concluded that the
whipping did not occur
it's something from the horse range from
a horse I I maybe the the video or the
picture was fixed but what I saw was
totally different I'm sorry um yeah I'm
gonna leave you as uh uh corrected
again
the Mexican border is not just Mexicans
it's Africans and Haitians what is there
in place as you hear from people who are
advocates for immigrants like Nana jumpy
to help those who are trying to seek
asylum in place from places like Haiti
that has gangs they can't even have an
election because things are the
atrocities there are just so great so um
a few um a few responses number one we
have set up the CBP one app
to enable people to make appointments
and arrive at ports of Entry safely if
they qualify for exceptions under the
public health authority of title 42
which of course is set to expire at 11
59 PM we have admitted approximately 740
people through that CBP one app per day
the majority of the individuals admitted
have been Haitian
uh we um are expanding that CBP one app
to reach as many as a thousand people a
day
um and we are setting up Regional
processing centers throughout the region
working very closely with countries to
the South working with Colombia and
others and we expect to set up as many
as a hundred or more of those processing
centers that will be open to people of
all nationalities to obtain humanitarian
relief
Mr secretary thanks for being here um
the president said this week that the
situation on the southern border is
going to be chaotic for a while given
the fact that you've had nearly two
years to prepare for this moment how can
chaos be the expectation well um I have
said for months and months uh that the
challenge at the border is and is going
to be very difficult and we have spoken
repeatedly about the fact that that
difficulty may actually only increase at
this time of transition it is going to
take a period of time for our approach
to actually gain traction and show
results and I've been very clear about
that the fundamental reason the
fundamental reason why we have a
challenge at our border and we've had
this challenge many a time before it's
because we are working within the
constraints of a broken a fundamentally
broken immigration system and we also
are operating on resources that are far
less than those that we need and that
we've requested some of the
I've been talking about to put in place
in mitigate this search some of those
aren't even in place yet it was it
wasn't until two weeks ago that you
announced these plans to open these
Regional processing centers as far as
I'm aware they're not open yet of the
1500 troops that the president deployed
only 550 are actually on the ground so
given how long you have known that title
42 is ending on May 11th why aren't all
these measures already in place so we
have implemented measures well before
those few that you identify are parole
processes would be an example while we
deployed 1500 additional Department of
Defense Personnel we've had 2500
Department of Defense Personnel well in
place already we have surged resources
of all types over months and months not
just Personnel but transportation
facilities technology additional bed
space so we have been in fact not you've
done all you can we have done all we can
with the resources that we have and
within the system that we are operating
under
couple questions Mr secretary thanks for
being here first on the CBP one app that
you were speaking about right now
migrants that are speaking to
journalists including our reporters on
the ground have indicated a series of
frustrations they say they're having
trouble logging on they're having
trouble getting appointments they're
having trouble with language barriers
perhaps they speak indigenous languages
or others and they're seeing technical
glitches right now so what specifically
is being done to fix that right now and
does that app provide false hope to
these migrants coming that will only
lead to Future frustration and surges
like we saw from Venezuelans only a
matter of months ago so um we have seen
a tremendous acceptance of the CBP one
app we are utilizing it very effectively
as I referenced earlier in response to
the reporters prior question that 740
people per day are reaching our Port of
Entry those by the way are not
individuals who've only made
appointments but actually a a fraction
of the people who have made appointments
using the CBP one app it is proven
successful
we have identified glitches and we've
done so not unilaterally exclusively but
also by speaking with individuals who
have used the app by speaking with
migrants here in the United States who
have reached the United States as well
as actually going into Mexico and
meeting with migrants to understand the
challenges if I may so we have addressed
the challenges of which we are aware the
greatest challenge with respect to the
CBP one app is not a technological
challenge but rather the fact that we
have many more migrants than we have the
capacity to make appointments for the
greatest level of frustration is
actually being able to make the
appointment not the utility of the CBB
one app itself that is again another
example of a broken immigration system
I'd like to follow up on a foreign
policy question though very broadly just
quickly the U.S sanctions U.S has
sanctions right now in a series of
foreign Nations on Cuba on Venezuela on
Nicaragua so does the Biden
administration's foreign policy make
this situation worse so I'm going to
leave that to our foreign policy
specialist but I will I will say this
the predicate of those um principles are
separate apart from the immigration
challenge that we're confronting Terry
and we're going to try and get around
terrified given the time you say this is
going to take and based on what you're
seeing now at the southern border and
Beyond in Mexico I wonder if you offer
some details paint a picture what should
Americans in those border communities
and Beyond expect in the coming days and
weeks what's this going to look like for
them we could see very crowded as we are
now we could see very crowded border
patrol facilities I cannot overstate The
Strain on our Personnel uh and our
facilities but we know how to manage
through such strain as difficult as it
will be I have tremendous confidence and
pride in our Personnel let me share with
you an example of how we manage through
a very difficult situation
in El Paso Texas we saw individuals on
the street we engaged in a very
sensitive and Humane law enforcement
operation to address that challenge and
we successfully have done so to the
praise of the city of El Paso can I just
follow our teams in El Paso say that
there are hundreds
in the open in shelter with very limited
access to food and water and bathrooms
for days why aren't they being processed
is that what we can expect so we are
working very closely with non-profit
organizations with Community groups to
really
deliver a community response to the
challenge I cannot understate
um uh I'm sorry I cannot overstate how
much of a challenge it is going to be
and how we all have to deal with it as
one Administration and one country
fundamentally fundamentally we need
Congress to act
Mr secretary
is this exclusively a challenge at the
land border or are you also seeing an
increase in a regular Migration by sea
to Florida and to California for that
matter and then secondly on the regional
processing centers I know that your
staff has said that you'll have more
announcements on exactly where those
will be in the coming days but just to
Echo my colleague's point you know the
you want those to be ready ahead of the
expiration of title 42 and can you give
any details on exactly where those
process
so with respect
to Maritime migration a number of months
ago we were experiencing
pressure in the maritime environment and
we responded to that pressure with
increased resources it is incredibly
perilous for individuals to take to the
Seas the search and rescue operations
that the United States Coast Guard has
to undertake all too often
to rescue people those seas are rough
and the vessels that they use are
extraordinarily flimsy and we see um
death on the high seas and so we we
plus stop our resources our Coast Guard
resources we also
activated more robustly the
reunification programs that give a
lawful pathway for individuals to reach
a country of safety right
right there was a second part to that
question sorry I'm sorry
oh the the regional processing centers I
apologize so the regional processing
centers that's not something that the
United States can set up unilaterally
within a matter of weeks this is a this
is a subject that requires a diplomacy
we rely on our foreign partners and it
takes a great deal of partnering not
only with the partners themselves but
also with the international
organizations that are part of the
fabric of international human uh
humanitarian relief the United Nations
High Commissioner for refugees the
International Organization for migration
and others
if you think it was your secretary
taxes arrived in front of the vice
president's office this morning vice
president's house this morning what's
your response to to that to more buses
of migrants being sent from Texas to
Washington DC
it is a both sad
um and tragic day
when a government official uses migrants
as a pawn for political purposes
thank you secretary for being here on
the memo that the U.S border Patrol
Chief sent to Secret Chiefs last night
allowing for parole releases if
overcrowding becomes an issue that's not
title eight like you said would happen I
mean these migrants don't get an alien
registration number that would be used
to track them they don't get a court
date they're instead asked to
self-report to ice within 60 days you
said at the beginning that you've
prepared for this moment for almost two
years so why is part of that plan and
honor System
oh it is it is not an honor System what
we what we do is we use the resources
that we have to meet the challenges that
we confront this is a tool that has been
used in the past the vast majority of
individuals will indeed be placed in
expedited removal and that if they do
not qualify will be removed in a matter
of days if not weeks from the United
States when we um when we encounter a
volume of individuals for which we need
to address in a different way we do so
if those individuals do not honor their
commitment to surrender to an
Immigration and Customs enforcement
officer to be able to be placed in
enforcement proceedings they are a
subject of our apprehension efforts
be a fraction of migrants that this
happens with how how many is a fraction
when you've had almost 6 million illegal
Crossings under this Administration
we last year
removed returned and expelled
approximately 1.4 million individuals
that is the most in any one year
shaky legal ground though with mass
releases well first of all
first of all your your question has a
factual predicate with which I would
disagree about Mass releases number one
but releases of individuals uh subject
to an immigration enforcement
proceedings is not something particular
to this Administration
case basis we
um we Implement uh our operations uh in
conjunction with the Department of
Justice and we have confidence in the
lawfulness of our actions thank you Mr
secretary are you concerned that the new
Asylum regulations will encourage more
children to meet their families since
unaccompanied kids are exempt uh no uh
no we are no we are not it is a
obligation for us to address the needs
of unaccompanied uh children uh so we do
not have that concern and what we are
driving to what we are fundamentally
driving to is to build lawful Pathways
so people do not have to take have to
make those difficult decisions and they
don't have to take the dangerous journey
in the first place and we are expanding
lawful Pathways to an unprecedented
degree under the president's leadership
just one more what is your assessment of
Mexico's enforcement of the Border we
are working very closely with the
government of Mexico the president has
spoken with the president of Mexico has
recently as earlier this week they have
corresponded last week and Mexico is
taking very important enforcement
measures that we greatly appreciate and
that were taken in coordination with us
secretary how is
that affect the backlog that's already
there for previous runs so so Peter your
your question if I may just to hit this
point once again
your question speaks of an Immigration
Court backlog that is exceeds two
million cases what a powerful example of
a broken immigration system not only are
we surging Asylum officers about a
thousand Asylum officers to conduct
credible fears screenings in the context
of expedited removal but the Department
of Justice is surging immigration judges
alongside us thanks sir if I could ask
you about the uh
the title eight enforcement you're
talking about you're trying to send a
message the critics of the
administration would argue this is a
message that you could and probably
should have sent earlier on in the
administration can you walk Us in
through the deliberation how did you
arrive at the idea that there should be
a presumption of ineligibility and why
was that uh policy not announced earlier
so um
in response to your precise question we
sought to end title 42 the public health
authority earlier we sought to roll out
our immigration enforcement authorities
under Title VII of the United States
code earlier we were enjoined from doing
so by a court
it's not it's not a message we don't
promulgate a regulation
we don't promulgate a law to send a
message we promulgated a law to achieve
a policy and operational outcome and the
outcome that we seek to achieve through
this regulation is to incentivize people
to take the lawful Pathways and
disincentivize them to place their lives
in the hands of Ruthless Smugglers
deterrence new regulation directing
migrants that's not a that's not a
message that's a that's an impact on
human behavior okay
thank you thank you secretary first um
have you ruled out family detention as
an option and then two you said that you
have many more migrants than you have
appointments for so is there any effort
to try to expand the appointments and do
you have numbers for how many
appointments are confirmed per day so we
are indeed expanding uh the use of CBP
one app from approximately 740
arrivals at our ports of Entry along the
southern border to a thousand uh a day
and we are exploring what other
capabilities we can add to that
um and the first part of your question
was family detention
this Administration ended family
detention in March of 2021.
bring it back at all we've made we've
made it clear that families who are in
Immigration enforcement proceedings
including uh in expedited removal
proceedings a more accelerated
immigration enforcement process will be
on alternatives to Detention of the
conditions of alternatives to detention
may be increased as the situation
warrants
to what so for example we could place
um heads of household under curfews so
that we are are better able to monitor
um uh their activities
um and I should say their compliance
with our restrictions and obligations to
appear in court
you are Orient me sorry
uh Mr secretary can you describe how you
will be treating any differently
migrants at the border that come from
countries where we don't have close
working relationship for example we've
seen reporting of migrants coming as far
from China Russia Syria and then my
second question I'm going to try to ask
Peter's question in a different way with
some Democrats urging that President
Biden and sanctions on Cuba and
Venezuela do you support that
um uh so the um you speak of different
demographics
um arriving uh at our our Southern
border this speaks to the fact that the
challenge of migration is not exclusive
to the southern border and is in fact
not exclusive to the Western Hemisphere
it we are seeing a global displacement
of people that is the greatest since at
least World War II uh the challenge of
encountering individuals from countries
that are uh to which it's not easy to
remove people has been a long standing
challenge that our immigration uh laws
uh have run into
you so uh we place them in in
Immigration enforcement proceedings and
uh they make if they make a claim for
Relief we adjudicate those claims and if
in fact those claims are granted then
they have under our laws a basis on
which to stay in the United States if
they do not then we work with foreign
governments to address the enforcement
actions that we think are appropriate
foreign
that is a little bit outside the remit
of today's discussion
your reaction to the immigration package
that House Republicans are looking to
vote on today and second question on the
processing centers was it a mistake to
not have them ready to prevent a surge
can you repeat the second part of that
question and I would say the president
President Biden uh presented congress
with a legislative package on day one of
this Administration now about 28 months
ago and we are hopeful that sensible and
needed legislative reform uh will be
passed by Congress and we do not concur
with the bill that was presented today
testing center specifically though was
it a mistake to not have them ready in
time to prevent surge as as I have said
the development of those processing
centers is a complex undertaking that
requires the work of our foreign
Partners International organizations and
like and we've moved very swiftly
Republicans repeatedly uh seek to paint
the administration as being unable to
secure the Border I wanted to ask do you
see this as a test does the
administration see this as a test or
possibly an opportunity uh to show the
American people that the administration
does have the ability to manage the
border under difficult circumstances
we um we view this as a challenge
a challenge that we will meet
also asked in regards to the
overcrowding in some of these difficult
conditions how long are we talking that
this chaoticness will be are we talking
weeks months years before things take
traction and you get more of a handle on
it we are working as hard as we can to
make sure that that time it takes is as
little as possible let me say um an
additional thing in response to your
your first question this is a challenge
and we're we're going to meet this
challenge
um we're going to meet it
within a broken immigration system
while adhering to our values
last year there were some estimates from
DHS officials putting the highest level
of migrants coming across the border
each day at about 18 000 if title 42 is
revoked is that still the estimate or do
you have a clear number of what you're
anticipating so
um let me clarify the numbers the number
that to which you refer
those weren't predictions it is our
responsibility in the Department of
Homeland Security and across the
administration to plan for different
scenarios that's what we do
and so what we developed was in fact
different scenarios to which we plan and
so we have done so and we continue to do
so
transition period but how long do you
expect a potential search to last are we
talking weeks months longer we have
confidence in the approach that we are
taking which is to to Really present
lawful Pathways for individuals to take
advantage of and to disincentivize
individuals from from really placing
their lives in the hands of Smugglers
and let me let me share with you that
the parole processes that we announced
and implemented on January 5th for
Cubans Haitians nicaraguans and
Venezuelans are a proof point
of the success of our approach we saw a
tremendous demand to access those lawful
Pathways and we saw a 90 over 90 percent
drop in the number of Encounters of
individuals from those four countries at
our Southern border and we saw that very
very quickly
to respond
um you know they point to border
Patrol's own numbers which show that
going back to October of last year there
were more than a million apprehensions
but then there were also more than 530
000 gotaways that's roughly the the size
of the population of the city of
Baltimore how can you say that the
border is not open
so we removed returned and expelled 1.4
million people last year asked those 1.4
million people who if they think the
border is open our apprehension rate at
the border is consistent with the
apprehension apprehension rate in Prior
years
and then in El Paso they've declared
thanks to the extraordinary work of the
United States border patrol
perhaps are they declared a state of
emergency but we've also seen this in
other cities like New York and Chicago
I'm wondering
um while so much of the focus is on the
southern border itself can you tell us
more about the steps that DHS is taking
to support those cities elsewhere as you
know this surge affects not just that
geography but other cities and states
across the country I would say though a
number of things number one we're
grateful uh to leader Schumer in
Congress for the emergency food and
shelter program funding in the Omnibus
this past December of 800 million
dollars that's a significant increase
over the prior Year's funding of 150
million dollars we're working very
closely with cities and communities
along the border and in the interior of
the United States we need the system
fixed
thank you thank you Mr secretary back to
the question of mass releases I know
you've pushed back against that but the
Florida attorney general has filed a
lawsuit against you alleging that you
are
to conduct a policy of mass releases
with the news that was released
yesterday what's your response to that
and more broadly what's your message to
the judicial branch who is playing a
role in this process as well well um I
don't I don't send messages to the
judicial branch
the judges make the decisions that they
believe are warranted under the facts
and laws uh before them but I will say
this
um it is
um
it is interesting to see some of the
tools that we employ that are successful
or operationally needed to be challenged
at the in in the courts so for example
the parole process that we announced and
implemented on January 5th for Cuban's
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans
immediately that demonstrated a
reduction in the number of those
individuals arriving at our Southern
border of over 95 percent and yet it's
been challenged in a court
and so our Parole Authority when we use
it to release a fraction of the people
whom we encounter and that is challenged
I question the motives of the plaintiffs
great now following up on the emergency
program that you just mentioned groups
in El Paso that are helping to feed in
the houses and collections of migrants
they say this program has a problem in
that the funding can only be used to
help migrants who have encountered DHS
and been processed does that requirement
realistic to the situation that these
communities are facing it is it is
necessary and I should say this past
Friday under the emergency food and
shelter program we distributed 332
million dollars primarily to border
communities we now have under the new
structure that the Omnibus that Congress
equipped us with we now have the shelter
and services program that we in the
Department of Homeland Security will
control that will prove I think more
Nimble and we I think have 363
not
not is there no way to help with the
addressing the humanitarian need there
so um just to finish my thought I think
we have about 363 million dollars to
distribute through the shelter and
services program and I believe that
non-governmental organizations in the
cities address the needs of individuals
who have not been processed
if you could raise your hand so I can
Orient
Orient visually oh thank you yeah thank
you
Terry so they were saying here the
Republicans have changed in
administration On the Border but at the
same time some Democrats are saying that
President Biden broke his promise of
having a more Humane uh immigration
system and that he's finishing Trump's
job so I ask you how is a more Humane to
expel people and penalize them and
people who are fleeing violence poverty
you're just saying that the number of
the deportation was the highest last
year of any year
so let me just the the words um uh have
legal significance so an expulsion is
what happens under the public health
authority of title 42. we sought to end
the application of title 42 some time
ago
um
this Administration stands markedly
different than the prior Administration
markedly different we have in fact a
family reunification task force that has
now reunified I think more than 700
families that were cruelly separated we
have by the prior Administration we have
rescinded the public charge rule that
punishes uh individuals who've migrated
to the United States just for accessing
public resources to which they are
entitled we have granted temporary
protected status to quite a number of
countries this president has led the
unprecedented expansion of lawful
Pathways We Stand markedly different
than the prior Administration we do not
resemble it at all what we do and by the
way we have rebuilt an asylum system
that was dismantled in the prior
Administration we have resumed Refugee
processing are all around the world and
these Regional processing centers are
going to accelerate the
support me the refugee process in an
unprecedented way we are a nation of
immigrants and we are a nation of laws
and those laws provide that if one
qualifies for humanitarian relief then
one has established a basis to remain in
the United States and if one has not
then one is to be removed and that is
exactly what is going to happen
what's the rough cost to American
taxpayers since the roughly 4 million
people have come into this country
illegally uh since January of 2021 as
those people show up in Community
Hospitals as they enter the school
system as they get other government help
do you have a taxpayer cost let me turn
that question uh around a little bit
because I'm going to turn it around to
match the question that an international
partner asked of me and the question
that the international partner asked of
me is what is the economic cost of your
broken immigration System since there
are businesses around this country that
are desperate for workers
there are desperate workers looking for
jobs
desperate workers in foreign countries
that are looking for jobs in the United
States where they can earn money
lawfully and send much needed
remittances back home what is the cost
of a broken immigration system that is
the question that I am asked and that is
the question that I pose to Congress
because it is extraordinary
now I I believe I have addressed your
question
what's standing in between is actually
being set up is it a Personnel thing is
it a matter of nailing down location
working out agreements with
International Partners just a little bit
more on that yes
yes okay yes it it it there are a lot of
moving pieces
said that the border is closed and
migrant Crossings continue to notch
records and you just said that your
message to migrants who are traveling
unlawfully is do not spend your life
savings coming here only to be
apprehended if and when you arrive here
but I'm wondering what you think it will
take for that message to land
um the questions are very important one
because it speaks of two things one is
of course the efforts we make but the
second is a phenomenon that we are
confronting and that is the smuggling
organizations that spread disinformation
uh to uh vulnerable migrants they
um lie to migrants and as a matter of
fact when I was in Panama
um speaking to my counterpart the
foreign secretary in Panama and the
secretary of the minister of security
they were speaking of the fact that
smugglers in that region of the world
before the migrants enter the darien an
incredibly treacherous terrain they are
deceived into thinking that they are
going to be on a two-day tour
and so the smuggling organizations prey
on the vulnerability of migrants and
exploit that vulnerability solely for
profit we are communicating to migrants
in country
to communicate the truth the dangers of
the journey the exploitation of the
Smugglers and just yesterday we
announced an extraordinary digital
campaign to amplify that messaging which
is so vital question
specifics on this plan
the migrants tomorrow
of those how many are going to be
detained how many will be caught and
released and how many will be removed
and returned within 72 hours so let me
let me share with you that we have
already encountered uh 10 000 uh
individuals in a single day uh you know
uh so we we already uh have proven that
we can manage through uh that we have
surged resources not just the Department
of Homeland Security but the Department
of Justice in bringing immigration
judges to work alongside Asylum officers
to address the expedited removal process
we have surged the resources that we
have
given the resources that we have been
given by Congress Which is less than
what we need and less than what we
requested to meet the challenge to the
best of our abilities thank you
thank you thank you very much Corinne
thank you all thank you
uh so guys we are way over time
um so even our amazing cleaning crew has
come in a couple times
uh so I I can take a couple of questions
but we have to we really have to wrap up
we've been going for almost I think
about an hour if not close
um okay exactly yeah uh it has to be
somebody I haven't called on yet
[Laughter]
wait the way in the back right there um
New Hampshire is my
today with Senator Dianne Feinstein back
in Washington does President Biden still
support him among apparent concerns from
some Democrats and what is the White
House doing to get him over the finish
line so look we take our our nominees
very seriously the president uh clearly
uh puts fourth nominees that he believes
are are ready and equipped for the job
and so of course we're always going to
be uh make sure that we do everything
that we can having conversations with
the Senators and their staff to try to
move our nominees through so we are
committed for certain um you had another
question in there was oh and then you
mentioned uh Senator Feinstein we're
glad to see her uh back as you know she
is a long time friend of of the
president and uh and we're we've been
he's been wishing her a speedy recovery
and it's glad to see her uh back uh back
in uh back in the Senate and I'll leave
that there
I was trying to figure out who got has
the president reached out to Senator
manchin after he settled a vote against
the EPA nominees or what's the plan to
get these nominees through if not so
like I don't have anything more to say
than what I shared yesterday on the on
on Senator manchin's uh comments look
Center Mansion as a friend we've been
able to do really historic uh move
forward some historic pieces of
legislation with Senator manchin
including the inflation reduction act
and other bipartisan infrastructure
bills and law now and other pieces of
legislation so we are going to continue
to have conversations with him we're
going to continue to have a good
relationship I just don't have anything
more than what I shared yesterday good
are you
can you update us on the talks about the
death ceiling and related to this uh
Donald Trump yesterday said that
Republicans should actually trigger
default if they don't get spending cuts
does that make a default more likely so
look I would uh remind you all what he
said in 2019 and first I got to be super
super careful uh let me just say that
first uh we respect the rule of law he
is a we know presidential candidate what
I will say more broadly and focus on
what what he said in 2019 how um
paraphrasing here how uh defaulting is
not something that we should be doing
and so the question is what has changed
what has changed now from 2019 to today
look we've been very clear that Congress
needs to do their job they must do their
job it's their constitutional duty to
get this done we've done it three times
under the last Administration we've done
it 78 times since 1960 but also like I
said I want to be very careful because
he is he is a presidential candidate but
I can speak to uh 2019 in his comments
about the importance of making sure that
we do not default and we're not a
deadbeat Nation
um I have another question on the
situation in the southern border so even
ahead of the chaos of this week morale
amongst border patrol agents is low
they've been through a lot with the
ongoing surge of people coming across
the border and according to the acting
Deputy Commissioner of the CBP 36 agents
died by suicide in the last three years
alone so what is President Biden doing
to show America's Frontline police that
he hears them and that he cares about
the unprecedented issues they're facing
and so look our hearts go out to those
families uh of uh of those law
enforcement members who as you just
stated
took their lives so look secretary
mayorkas spoke to this he actually
lifted up the the CBP
and said the work that they're doing is
truly tremendous this is why the
president has taken this so seriously
making sure that we have troops that go
down to the border so that they can give
some relief to the CBP uh the patrol of
the law enforcement and be able so that
they can be able to do their jobs right
and so that's why we put that we put
forth and what we have seen on our end
is you've seen House Republicans who
have voted to fire 2000 law enforcement
those those same CBP members they voted
to fire at least two thousand voted
against giving giving resources for
folks who are at the border for DHS for
these law enforcement
officers and so the president is doing
everything that he can with the tools
that he has in front of him that's why
he asked Congress on his first day
please we have a comprehensive plan in
front of you we want you to we want you
to take a look at this we want to fix a
system that has been broken for decades
you heard the secretary said since 1990s
and so it is time to get to work the
president is doing everything that he
can we understand there's a challenge at
the border but we have are going to
continue to put forth a robust
multi-agency process to deal with an
issue that has been around for decades
and decades
trying to see who I have not called go
ahead Karen
um two updates on when the president and
Congressional leaders will meet tomorrow
how much time the president's allotting
for that meeting and can you give us an
update on the staff meeting that took
place since that principal's meeting
absolutely so I don't have any updates
for you yet for tomorrow as you know the
president asked the four leaders uh the
Congressional leaders to come together
again tomorrow to follow up on a
conversation that they had just a couple
of days ago as you know we don't read
out private conversations and we
certainly don't negotiate in public but
I can confirm as you all have been
reporting that the staff met yesterday
to follow up on the conversation to talk
about uh Congressional leaders to the
four Congressional leaders and how they
saw moving forward on budget and
spending that's regular order that is
something that has been done year after
year to talk about Appropriations and so
the staff are meeting again today and
don't have anything further uh beyond
that but certainly we will share once we
have a time and more information and
Logistics to share on tomorrow's meeting
visited the Spanish president tomorrow
is there a two and two press conference
that's been added for that I don't have
a press conference to read out to you as
you know we are the president's very
much looking forward to speaking uh to
speaking uh with the leader I just don't
have anything more to share I'm sure NSC
will be holding some sort of background
call more information to share with all
of you okay I'm going to take one more
go ahead Courtney I'm just trying to
call guys I'm trying to call on people
that I have not
we're going to put in place a plan for
the White House
have a pandemic preparedness office up
yet Dr jaw hasn't said if he's leaving
but I know his team is unwinding Dr
wilinski's leaving can you talk a little
bit about the leadership that's going to
be in charge of coven moving forward
especially if the tools that we have
that you've been discussing don't work
at a certain point or don't work as well
so I don't have anything to share I know
you just asked me about the kova team we
did as I mentioned at the top we're we
do have an office of pandemic
preparedness as I've mentioned multiple
times it was in the Omnibus budget
package for fiscal year 2023 so Congress
called on us to establish this office so
we are working through that and once we
have more information we will share that
with all of you I will be back tomorrow
everybody and it will take we'll take
more information I'll I'll I'll be back
tomorrow guys thanks everybody